iOS now includes a new system for
positioning UI elements on screen,
called Auto Layout.
You can think of Auto Layout as a simple
adaptive system to help iOS figure out
how to size and
position your user interface element.
You can use it to ensure that
your UI elements are sized and
positioned correctly, from the smallest
iPhone to the largest iPad.
In this course, we're going to go
further in-depth on Auto Layout.
And in particular, constraints.
How to use constraints on user
interface elements and views.
Auto Layout is very powerful.
But it takes a little bit of practice
for it to become second nature.
Right now, you're just starting.
Remember, it's okay to be frustrated and
not to get it right on
the first few tries.
Keep on it.
And with very little time, you will
become comfortable with this powerful
and flexible system for
positioning and sizing UI elements.